hello and welcome to the you're playing
age odm never played him let's see ya
uncle Queens gambit pusher a form yep
let's play c5 and always believed that
this is the only move that at least give
some challenge to black and the move
seemed very equal ish here black also
has good equalizing chances but it's not
yeah it's not simplifying at least early
or quickly let's say ya hear b5 is
interesting but I think ultimately also
not convincing let's see here
and I probably take play be 50 be five
immediately and I have a far though that
seems a little bit less precise I
thought that looks a little bit strange
to be honest
should just take it on before there was
no why not you have to open up the FR
for you anyway so okay I'm even taking
as an option but be five is the the
normal move and also the good-looking
move so what now roop chicks I guess
looks like the most powerful
okay yeah now the wise is better for
white my protected pass on c5 is much
stronger then it's blocked a porn and
I've got the beef I'll ideas rupee seven
if possible
yeah it's a really bad position and ok
let's see taken could be five I don't
want to trade really that much ok rupee
seven wasn't wasn't the best
and I'd be six also not yet not yet so
convincing I don't win da porn
unfortunately my night years also not
doing much I didn't want to do that
originally but my knight on f3 is not
very helpful maybe I should have still
played 95 though and I'd be six no he
cannot take so should be a relatively
good moment to play this as I will take
a five there's enough in a fork so he
cannot cannot grab and take a five
black resins on it but early but ok I'm
it really is bad yeah he screwed it up
with with this premature a five here
after roop you wanna know he just has to
take and now if you want to go be five
which is not sure that you want but then
you can do it now or you can also go
like Google III here black has has
equalized I think as it usually does in
that line simply not much to do them
yeah this is wrong after a four why does
get it better be five yeah this is
exactly the position that we there be
God and the problem is that the C porn
is so much stronger than the a pond and
this was okay rupee seven here I missed
Luke 67 I mean I saw the move but what I
didn't see I don't see why this is so
brilliant of course I take a--take here
and then I have rupee aid ok that was a
simple miss okay but I just I just kept
the position as is it's a ni p 6 was
even stronger here the queen is no
squares okay I'm I played the second
best moves a couple of times but it is
it is good enough for this winning
position which he resigned a bit early I
mean you can try to hang on here but it
is it is really bad with the protected
see extra porn passer no black should be
able to hold it okay well thanks for
watching